there's so much clickbait out there
because it's such an effective way to
get people to pay attention to things
because as you said people focus on
failure and negative and anger that's
what we want to see controversy that's
what we want to see people don't want to
see the anger yeah and and you know we
think that is because it's just the
times it's it's that's what's cool now
always being negative you know how you
always have some people it's a great
example how you have people mean you can
talk about a movie all right we can talk
about Titanic wow that's authentic one
of the biggest movies of all time
fucking great movie yes it was great
movie and one guy for no reason go I
fucking hated it why you're like Titanic
fucking bullshit
why manga yeah I know what tell me why'd
you hate it I got time talk about that
the cool thing is just being different I
wanna I wanna be completely opposite
Denali Contreras how the people you know
what no no that shit was ass what Wow
Wow why was it ass if you have people
that just like to do this oh yeah for
sure and and and what happens when one
person does it another person for no
reason all go yeah me too
yes it was ass man i hain't like it
either did you see it what y'all talkin
about you don't even know what they're
talking about but you just want to hop
on the negative train right because
that's what's cool it's not cool to be
positive it's not cool to be happy I
don't know if it's a cool thing I think
it's usually people that are really
frustrated with their lives
100% what's the that's the factual side
to it I did a joke before I was like do
you think Michael Jordan leaves YouTube
comments like I bet he does now people
want to get mad and complain constantly
about shit like that do you know what it
takes to do this right here you know
right here no tell you how I feel
write in your comments section Joe Rogan
you can kiss my you know what that takes
what do you have
going on that you have the time to just
simply be that negative and in do it in
this world you know it's just a
mismanagement of your time yeah it is so
valuable and and I don't think people
understand how valuable they can be if
they use their time correctly yes now
have you always been like this
oh my fucking god man but always always
really I find a light in every dark
tunnel I will find a goddamn light man I
hear it all you listen when I tell you
to wait on my back it's so heavy of all
the stuff that I deal with and I'm fine
the reason why I'm fine is because I'm
genuinely happy I'm happy and I'm not
happy just because of the success
success X is a bonus I'm happy because I
truly know the definition and the
feeling that comes with happiness I
truly know it I felt it I felt it when I
said yo what really makes me happy and I
look at heaven and Hendrix and I look
his oh I look at my wife I go yo I
didn't have the family shit when I was
coming up yeah I got one I got one
look what I did look what I built these
people depend on me I provide for these
people that makes me happy
that makes me happy when my daughter
comes up dad
you're not only my dad you're my best
friend yo I'm happy that's my world so
everything else from the outside that
comes in your your your throwing shit at
a bubble that can't be popped mmm it's a
force field around me yeah it's a force
field around me because what matters
what really matters loves me
wholeheartedly and when you had that and
you understand that you're unbreakable
so if you don't add to that force field
if you don't make my force field
stronger you don't you don't you don't
get time for me my team heartbeat
productions the people underneath my
umbrella you're part of my force field
you believe what I believe we all see
the same things we want the same things
so we march with the same beat you can't
you can't shake that when you're an
individual that seen that and
understands that if you've never felt
that if you have no idea what that feels
like and it's easy to shake you that's
why some people are easily broken being
broken is not a hard thing it's not a
hard thing so those that do get broken
those that do get down those that do get
depressed I understand I understand
I don't I don't knock people for it mmm
I don't not anybody for it
what I also understand is that the
encouragement that can come from so many
can add value for those that may need a
little push hmm that may need a little a
Mempa Cucina it's so easy to be that
positive reinforcement for somebody and
add value it's so easy but some people
choose to throw that aside and kick
while you're down mmm I try to put out
the light of positivity because
whoever's out there you I don't know
what it could do for somebody else but
somebody else may just simply look at me
say you know the waiting hand braces his
kids it makes me want to be a better
father Yahweh did this man doesn't stop
and wait it every day he wakes up and
he's just positivity Garza what's going
on makes me realize that this shit ain't
so bad the way that he gets up and says
hey today is another day it's the
morning let's all be better than we were
yesterday somebody probably needed to
hear that the more that I can give that
out and I can take my platform to throw
good energy out I'm doing my part
because there's so many that throw out
the complete opposite yeah I don't want
to be a part of that that's beautiful
man that's and that's true I believe you
it's not it's not forced right it's not
phony yeah it's not fake it should every
day I hear shit every day it's very
contagious too I had a lady I heard a
lady right
[Laughter]
lady rolled out a window when you gonna
make a good movie again did you see the
upside was good what's that
oh shit it's a movie it's one of my
movies that's how I think I think it's a
good movie
I see that alright ma'am you have
beautiful day that's with such
conviction like literally yeah I could
have said a lot of shit like she rolled
a window down you could tell she still
had the crank things I could say to you
ma'am when you go make a good movie it's
napping I got one out the upside you see
the outside what's that it's a movie so
it's out now amazing that that's how she
chose to come out here I see it I'm
Jesus to come at you with a negative I
get it every day when you'll be funny
again I'm trying my best trying my best
if it's not working for you hopefully I
do better soon
what are you what what am I gonna feed
into that and it why right why why for
what yeah for what it seems to have been
working thus far are you getting this
positive attitude towards life from life
experience are you getting it from books
did someone teach you how to find this
I'm getting it from the experiences and
from the the real understanding of
perfection doesn't exist don't exist Oh
mmm we're in a time right now where
people expect perfection you expect
perfection I don't know where this came
from I don't know what happened that
this is the criteria for living
my true understanding is all right you
got one life and then one life the goal
for us is to live it to the best of our
ability from the beginning to what said
the end in the middle in the beginning
middle you're gonna do things you're
gonna make mistakes you're gonna fuck up
you're supposed to learn and then move
forward with the understanding of what
not to do and when you move forward life
may get better it may not but somewhere
along the lines is gonna click and
everything I would do back here was
supposed to happen so that now that I'm
here I'm able to go ahead with such a
high level of knowledge and I can make
other people better I can make myself
better I could do more for my family
something happens my dad is the prime
example crazy drug addict in and out of
jail life was very bad very fucking bad
my dad son got successful son then took
money gave it to his dad here's your
house here's your truck here's your
monthly at this age I want you to live
your life you don't make mistakes you
can't rebuild and correct the things
you've done I'm your son I love you you
can't go back in and redo you can't try
to keep going backwards and about me you
got grandkids mmm gonna be the best
grand pop you could be for these
grandkids that's your focus now where's
this energy devoted to being a grand pop
for the grandkids don't worry about me
but something happening in life
something happened that took you in the
direction to reap the benefits of your
son's happiness and success my energy is
now contagious nothing I hand it to you
so now you're able to give that off to
all these other people that you're
around something happens and that's in
every single life in every life I
understand that there's a payoff for bad
eventually there's a payoff it can't be
bad but for so long if you got the
strength and the understanding to
realize that shit will change it will
change it's impossible
just like poker I don't know if you play
poker or not no don't you play poker you
can run bad forever but it will
eventually turn around once you grasp
the understanding of the game eventually
it's going to turn around
blackjack you're never gonna be the
casino but eventually you're gonna have
a good run if you catch your run you'll
do good get the fuck out of there you
waited long enough for it to happen here
come catch it leave anything in life
will eventually turn good no but